another five now when you look at it
it's monic that's great right so
normally just think of paradigm is that
does what adds to negative 1 and
multiplies to negative 3 right except
you think and think and think you don't
get very far do you write because 33 is
prime so your only choices I wanted
three right and no matter which ones you
make negative they're never going to add
up to make up we learn to do technique
not sure I Z we learned is kinds of
questions right what do we do we're
going to complete the square okay so
hold on to your hats let's write the
quest the to complete the square is our
this negative three over here it's
what's stopping this thing being a
perfect square we want this to be a
paragraph put over the other side get
them out of the way okay and now I've
written this you notice I always leave
this gap here that gap is so i can add
something in to complete the square ok
so here there's a minus one there right
so what number do i add to complete the
square i have to take that minus one I
have to uh of and then have and then
square that number which will make this
left-hand side a complete square okay a
perfect fit so when you have it that
gives you minus a half and when you
square that you get a quater UK with
that I add it to the left I'd better add
it to the right okay all right now once
i have that the reason why I did that to
the left hand side is because now it's a
perfect square what's a perfect square
off I'll give you a clue it starts with
an ex okay you can start to narrow this
down right I see how there's a minus
side there that means the su- here right
and the number that we got here which
halved that's gonna be the number that
ends up here it's a half okay because
remember if you read backwards if you
went up there you expended this right
that half will get squared and turn into
a corner all right okay so now I have
what's his 32 corner that can be some
it's like 13 / 4 not really so I'm just
going to leave that as 32 quarter okay
all right this is great now it's
factorized kind of by using this
complete the square business but I want
to get that x by itself so next step
I'll take the square root of both sides
good that gets rid of the square on the
left hand side what is it due to the
rain it gives me the square root right
but also also just like if I gave you
the equation x squared equals 25 x is
not just five right there's another knob
which does that it's plus or minus right
good so just like it's possible bonus
there I'm going to get plus or motors
here ok and now this is one last thing
to do to get that x by itself push that
half over the other side now I suppose
you could probably eat this up you could
do some rationalizing business but
honestly this is the main thing we're
trying to work out can we complete the
square here go through the students test
cause it's quite tricky right and the
fact that it's quite tricky something
will deal with later this lesson okay
okay while stricken one yeah this will
go here to here that's true yeah okay so
let me give you a simpler example
perhaps okay if I gave you an example
like this let's make it don't make it a
minus okay here's an example right now
the reason why this is easier is cuz I'm
not going to end up with fractions right
so I deliberately gave me whether it was
a bit hard just pushing them sort of it
if I complete the square over here I'm
gonna get that if the other side okay
and then I think what will I add to this
what will I add now I have a two-out
there so what number do i need to add to
complete the square it'll be one right i
have it which gives me 1 square which
gives me one okay but I need to take
advantage of the fact that I reckon
older but i have had been given
questions and i can you square this and
can you squirt this can you square this
they all
end up at this same kind of format right
just like you learn to recognize square
numbers like that right you're like oh
you look at a noble you think I know
that kind of number I recognized it
right this algebraically is the same
kind of thing it's this it's a square
but in algebra terms right so you look
at that you think I know what this is
it's that guy right so that's how I went
from here to here it's not really clear
in terms of working because there isn't
much working to do it's a recognition
thing right so that is part of what's
hard about its complete the square which
is why I'm going to teach you to
alternative to complete the square today
okay now six is a bit more challenging
right because again it's not morning
every time you add more of those kinds
of layers of complexity and it's hard
right so 3x squared plus 2x minus 1 okay
again you look you think can I factorize
it what would you do what para numbers
you want yeah okay so if i go 3x squared
hold on negative 3 positive 3 negative 1
right so positive 3 and negative 1 up
sorry that's an X latest one okay so i
can factorize this guy by taking out 3x
and he are that's just going to be x + 1
i'm actually going to stop there if
that's ok because i think you guys know
what to do after that you're going to
pair them up you're going to read your
solutions on ok so last one under the
review and i'll admit that's a bit
sneaky but when you have a look at it
who's how to go hoos are it hands up
straight ok I'm going to pause for a
second that's not many of you I want all
of you to have a try at it wherever
you're up to just pause maybe leave a
bit of space if you need to and have a
go at number seven I've already walked
you through how you might do those
earlier questions and you can use a
certain techniques just give it a shot
just see what happens I'm going to
unpack this the same way I did before I
can't think of my factorization neatly
so I'm going to give this complete the
square bizness shot ok that [ __ ] that
plus 2 I want to make it a negative 2 on
the other side like so
oh and then I think oh ok what will I
add to this to complete the square right
what do I add I had a quarter again no
no it's ok now when you look at the left
hand side you think sweet I've done my
perfect square business that was the
whole point right so when I factorize is
right but then with a hand side minus 2
plus a quarter I'm doing my numbers
right now you agree is that ok so check
out now this is a problem this is a
problem for us it's a big trouble right
because we're saying there's some number
where if you sweat thing squared will
get a big if not more something has gone
wrong right because no matter what
number you put in there you can put in a
positive number you can put in the
fracture you can put a zero you can put
in a negative number don't number that
we are familiar with can be squared and
give you a negative number it's just so
okay what happened if you get your
calculator app and you say hmm well
maybe my calculator will help me out and
I'll put in square root of negative one
in three quarters right and it does that
ever so unhelpful thing and says math
error which is basically it's kind of
like the map the calculator is
equivalent saying I don't know okay so
what are we gonna do with this right as
it happens at this point once you
recognize that it wants to square get a
negative there aren't actually I
delicious to this and so we say no real
solutions that's it you can pack up and
go home you don't have to just sort of
wonder what does this mean it means
there are these solutions okay now this
is not the midpoint of our lesson today
but because it just naturally comes out
of this I want to show you what this
means see this quadratic up here x
squared plus X plus 2 one of the big
reasons we go through all of this
exercise of factorizing blah blah blah
blah blah is so that if I took the same
thing x squared plus X plus to you and
said that's y equal that I can graph
this thing
I can graph i can draw a picture of what
it looks like you guys have seen
travelers before right now this is a bit
of a strange problem so I've just done
my normal thing which is where you don't
know what how what something looks like
you just start plotting some points okay
I know how to do a table of values you
can do that for anything even if it's
really weird complicated okay so this is
my table of values you can go ahead and
you can check it out for x equals
negative 1 for instance how did I get
that negative 1 squared is 1 plus
negative 1 so those guys cancel I just
think you with the two I put an x equals
0 0 plus 0 plus 2 you get the idea okay
so off of this bless you I have four
coordinates okay so I'm just going to
quickly draw these you write minus 1
clubber to grab my bad being go minus 1
4 1 2 3 4 4 mg seven let's put that
about there here's my first point minus
one clever to this guy 0 comma 2 is
going to be here this guy 1 comma 1 2 3
4 something like that and then so 28
like now this is all I've traced out so
far I know that parabolas every single
parameter of the world is symmetrical so
if I'm getting their shape I'm guessing
it's going to do something like this
okay now you have a look at this shape I
look really weird any other words okay
but I love it can you tell me when is
this graph when is this graph equal to 0
where does it intersect with the x-axis
and the answer is it never does right
it's keep going up this way it's going
to keep going up and that's as low as it
goes it never comes beneath so it never
hits the x axis but that when does thing
hit yet 20 and our conclusion was it
does it right in fact lots of quadratics
don't they just never intersect okay so
this is what that means this is actually
what the picture is telling you okay so
there are no real solutions and you will
get you know at quadratics like this and
when I try and trick you we're trying to
see if you recognize
like what's the meaning of this theme a
classic air the students make is they
get to hear and they think oh well
there's a negative my calculator tells
me math error so i guess i'll just take
out the negative right and then take
that square root because that shows we
don't really understand what's going on
okay so that negative is meaningful and
it means there's no real solutions okay